en pleine crise de coronavirus le
paludisme lui progresse en afrique plus
de 700 mille morts en 2020 c'est le
sombre pronostic silo de l'om est ce si
jamais les programmes de prévention de
la maladie venait à pâtir de la pandémie
en 2018 l'afrique subsaharienne
représenter environ 93 % de tous les cas
de paludisme dans le monde et 94 % des
décès plus des deux tiers d'entre eux
concernent les enfants de moins de cinq
ans selon le dernier rapport de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
aujourd'hui comme chaque 25 avril c'est
la journée mondiale de lutte contre le
paludisme pour en parler direction le
cameroun avec olivia une gouge
fondatrice et directrice exécutive de
l'omg impact santé afrique il ya une
grue bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors cette année à
cause du coronavirus cent mille enfants
supplémentaires pourrait mourir du
paludisme selon les ong la vision du
monde est ce que vous partagez cette
terrible analyse oui absolument nous
partageons cette analyse et nous pensons
que nous pouvons même avoir une grande
crise liée au paludisme surtout en cette
période de kovy 19 parce que nous
craignons des perturbations et des
interruptions décor de campagne à haut
impact de lutte contre le paludisme
comme les distributions de moustiquaires
imprégnées qui ont arrêté de se faire
dans plusieurs pays et alors que nous
savons que nous approchons aussi la
saison des pluies dans les pays qui sont
donc des périodes à haute transmission
du paludisme
de plus nous savons que le paludisme
malheureusement après ce même si que le
coc vie d'isner donc la fièvre les
combattue par exemple et le personnel de
santé commencent à être heureux
retissant par rapport aux populations
qui se présentent avec des symptômes de
fièvre et les populations aussi encore
d'aller dans le centre de santé parce
qu'elle classe lorsqu'elles ont la fière
parce qu'elles ont peur d'être accepté
par le cos vie de 19
elle a justement on sait que dans de
nombreux pays les services hospitaliers
consacre
tous leurs efforts à la lutte contre le
coronavirus qu advient-il des malades du
paludisme
oui exactement alors s'il très c'est une
situation très compliquée parce que le
personnel de santé et et comme vous le
savez stressé par la crise de kobe 19 et
nous avons aussi certaines personnels de
santé qui sont mis en quarantaine
lorsqu'ils ont été exposés à des
personnes infectées par le commissaire
déjà nous dans notre contexte africain
nous n'avons pas assez de personnel de
santé en nombre suffisant pour couvrir
tous les besoins
donc imaginez si une partie de ce
personnel est mis en quarantaine
ça fait que on n'aura pas le personnel
et les ressources nécessaires pour
prendre en charge les cas de paludisme
et nous commençons a remarqué qu'à une
baisse de consultation dans les centres
de santé pour les fier alors que nous
savons que en saison des pluies et
surtout vous pendant cette période il y
aura plus d'épisodes de fièvre due au
paludisme
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes le 25
avril c'est donc la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le paludisme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire concrètement quelles sont
les actions qui vont être menées quelle
communication allez-vous faire autour de
cette journée oui alors le thème de la
journée césaire paludisme je m'engage
mais nous disons 0 paludisme ne se fera
pas tant qu'on continuera à avoir des
interruptions des campagnes de
sensibilisation et aussi des campagnes
de distribution des outils de prévention
du paludisme
alors nous avons commencé déjà des
campagnes sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que malheureusement on ne peut pas faire
d'activités de mobilisation sociale en
personne à bord
des mesures de confinement dans tout
notre communication est accentuée sur
les réseaux sociaux avec des messages
clés particulièrement aux populations
pour leur rappeler qu'il ne faut pas
oublier la musique imprégnait il ne faut
pas oublier les outils de prévention
parce que les moustiques n'attendrons
pas que le pot vide cinespace et aux
leaders nous leur demandons d'investir
davantage dans les systèmes de santé et
dans les systèmes de santé
communautaires non seulement pour
répondre au bond et me émergentes comme
kobe 19 mais aussi pour répondre aux
épidémies comme le paludisme qui tue des
milliers et des milliers de
personne en afrique 405 me laissais
répertoriés par l'om est en 2019 avec 94
% de ces décès en afrique donc nous
avons des épidémies qui continue à tuer
beaucoup de personnes dans nos pays
africains et il faudrait absolument que
nous que nos leaders investissent
davantage dans les systèmes de santé
pour répondre à toutes ces pandémies et
si vous nous ne faisons pas attention
nous risquons nous nous risquons d'avoir
une crise plus de décès liés au
paludisme que hank en 2018 ou 2019
nalaga chiffre 1 qui risque de doubler
pour 2020 en tout cas merci beaucoup
olivia nguu d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous étiez en
direct du cameroun où vous êtes
fondatrice et directrice exécutive de
l'omg impact santé afrique
merci beaucoup merci à vous